rosaire en pis pour les nuits fauves
peut-on le dire faut-il le dire en tout
cas lui les cris cyril collard par cyril
collard bonsoir quant à fait math spé
maths sup docks de maths et puis un jour
179 n'a eu ras-le-bol
j'ai dit je m'étais trompé d'existence
étaient partis non
[Musique]
oui je suis parti j'ai abandonné tout le
monde des études jour au lendemain dans
tu sais on dit du jour au lendemain
c'est ça se fait pas ça se fait quand
même en quelques mois mais je suis parti
à porto rico
j'ai commencé à écrire c'était bien et
puis merci
et puis j'ai aussi changé de manière de
vivre et manger les gens autour de moi
manger 2
sexualisé aussi enfin pas complètement
un peu à moi il va y venir alors venant
de porto rico donc été assistante pialat
sur loulou sur police sur quoi wesh
l'école j'ai connu fiala à la faim de
loup et j'ai fait avec lui à nos amours
et police ensuite tu as fait des courts
métrages salle g la blonde qui a été
primé dans leur loge alger la blanche
la blanche était privée dans pas mal de
festivals épitaphe et des clips tafer
carte de séjour si j'ai fait douze
france de carte de séjour j'ai fait deux
clips pour graziella de michel way
et puis les porte-manteaux aussi et puis
kassiry un chanteur ivoirien
voilà tu as fait une émission de tv qui
s'appelle revenez quand vous voulez
qu'ils étaient supprimées
malheureusement tu as fait un premier
livre qui s'appelait condamné amour qu
un très beau très beau tee et il est en
effet un deuxième qui s'appelle les
nuits fauves ça parle de sexe convient
de dire pour commencer c'est à dire tu
dis je suis accroché au sexe comme des
calmes et à la drogue oui je crois qui s
je parle de gens qui
sur qui effectivement le sexe pèse comme
une espèce de fatalité en masturbation
sans arrêt performances sexuelles
étonnant c'est possible ça je vais avec
chapeau qui s'annonce sur un lit ils se
branchent quoi je veux dire il va pour
s'endormir is bliss lavisse brand il se
lave les gens y croient c'est pas
possible ça tu exagères j'exagère pas
beaucoup non mais tu sais l'écriture
c'est aussi une concentration des choses
ouais leur vie sexuelle bon oui les
bisexuels et les étoiles
moi aussi on peut aussi parce que c'est
lui ou c'est toi écoute l'autobiographie
c'est toujours un truc banques c'est la
question qu'on pose à tous les gens que
j'ai perdu mon général tu sais ce que je
fais on va pas manquer de se la poser
oui oui bon c'est un roman c'est un
moment parce que parce que je revendique
qui a une écriture que c'est littéraire
maintenant les choses dont je parle
même si elles sont pas toutes
exact il y en a qui sont inventés mais
en général ce sont des choses qui sont
passés par mois ces endroits dont tu
parles comme ça à ces souterrains de la
ville en face et des espèces de back
room en plein air c'est où ces endroits
comme ça où les gens se voir et moi je
suis décrit un endroit qui était entre
près de la gare d'austerlitz et entre
austerlitz et entre le pont d'austerlitz
et le pont de bercy
c'est pas très grave l'endroit où ça se
trouve pas ce que je vais pas faire un
itinéraire fléché banide n'ont jamais
raghid simplement c'est l'idée aussi que
condescendant un autre ordre
le coach ne sont pas pareils cas la
surface que qu'est-ce qui se passe il se
passe que il ya un type qui vient
chercher de plaisir immédiat qui vient
chercher autre chose que ce qu'ils
trouvent dans les lieux dans les
hiérarchies de la surface
un autre c'est un autre un autre ordre
c'est un autre des pouvoirs sont pas les
mêmes
la communication est pas là mais il n'y
a pas de mots
juste des frôlements juste du sexe à la
brute quoi c'est du sexe âge et à bosser
surtout aussi une manière de d'arriver à
satisfaire ses fantasmes
il a souvent moi ouais ça m'arrive ça
t'arrive la dernière fois c'est fait
qu'en moyenne à moi ah ouais quand même
alors un jour le personnage ou toi
découvrait que vous êtes séropositif ça
se passe comment cette découverte à
quelle occasion tu fais le test
votre seul test tu fais mon personnage
je le dire il le fait par simplement
parce que le test mais existé et c'est
quand même assez récent et j'ai
finalement la peur elle et l'angoissé
les surtout plus grande avant je crois
parce que avant tout petit c'est pour
moi je vais y avoir droit à quoi
peut-être que c'est parce que parce que
celle éducation judéo-chrétienne fait de
conscience de la faute une fiabilité la
comptabilité mois comme tu disais je
suis parti d'une j'avais une voie tracée
qui était une autre et puis je changer
j'ai bifurqué
et puis peut-être qu'il ya une faute
l'idée de la côte qui arrive comme ça et
que je me suis dit voilà c'est pour moi
mais finalement quand le test est fait
d'une certaine manière on a moins peur
et quand est dictée positive même si
c'est une espèce de lutte qui commence
mais pas vraiment justement on y viendra
parce que moi je trouve que enfin le
personnage à partir du moment où il sait
qu'il est séropositif
on pourrait penser qu'il va se mettre à
vivre calmement qui valait à la campagne
boire du bon lait de vache et puis
qu'est-ce qui fait ils pourront jamais
autant de co qui prend jamais autant de
braun et il sort jamais autant la nuit
comment ça se fait ça c'est suicidaire
complètement ça non je crois que c'est
une évolution
d'abord la lutte laissez pas quelque
chose d'extérieur c'est pas c'est pas
des vitamines et les corn flakes et à
l'intérieur de soi la lutte
et puis si tu as bien vu dans le livre
que effectivement il ya il ya des
histoires de coco début et il ya de la
drogue mais ça se termine pas comme ça
ça ils abandonnent tous à peu à peu le
fait d'être séropositif c'est pas une
exclusion dans sa peau nous sommes enfin
a priori on aura envie de se ranger un
peu des voitures mange pas pourquoi
n'ont envie de vivre c'est tout photo i
jy voyez une fille au milieu de tout ça
c'est une ville qui a 17 ans et qu est l
es complètement romantique elle n'est
pas du tout dans dans cet univers de
l'accélération de la multiplication
parce que je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment important dans
livre c'est la confusion quoi c'est que
ce soit de narrateur que ce soit sa
ninja mêle ses personnages a cédé jean
divisé quoi qu'ils sont un peu coupé en
morceaux une confusion la fois affective
idéologie logique logique leur mentalité
c'est des petits bouts collés les uns
des tubes aux idéologies différentes
collés les uns à côté des autres et elle
au contraire
et elle est amoureuse de ce mec et elle
veut que lui et elle est elle accepte le
risque de la contamination
elle accepte pas vraiment cyril parce
qu'au départ la première fois le
personnage lui dit pas alors ça c'est
lui dit pas c'est quand même une forme
d' assassinat en quelques sortes nom de
faire l'amour avec quelqu'un quand on
est séropositif sans lui dire mais il se
trouve que dans le livre
je crois que c'est clairement dit que ça
se termine bien puisque le film est
passé au sort a eu du mal se terminer
mal se terminer mais je crois que c'est
le bon là on en revient toujours à
l'histoire de la faute
pourquoi est ce qu il lui dit pas
progress qui me dis pas simplement parce
que nancy c'est un peu là oui parce que
dans cette espèce d'accélération de sa
vie c'est un c'est un truc complètement
je dédie morcelé divisé qui va très vite
tout d'un coup avec cette fille là
l'impression que que vraiment c'est une
histoire d'amour ils y croient bon il
n'ose pas lui dire tout simplement ces
sénateurs ont en fait la fille elle
souffre plus du fait qu'ils soient
bisexuels que la séropositivité en
vérité elle en souffre beaucoup plus
parce que lui il arrive pas à se
détacher des garçons et elle le fait
enfin il a fait tourner en bourrique
disons pour et il ya une chose qui est
pas mal dans le bouquin c'est que
l'histoire d'amour est racontée sur
répondeur c'est assez moderne c'est à
dire que on nous ment nous on ne sait de
leur histoire que les messages qu'elle
lui laisse sur le répondeur je crois que
c'est ça fait aussi partie comme la
maladie comme la confusion comme les
confusions ça fait partie du
de cette espèce de kaléidoscope de la
modernité pour moi un moment qu'elle
sait assez fort il ya un ami qui se fait
bastonner sans doute aucun problème avec
des néo nazis
et puis tu remplis une seringue et tu
dis je vais lui je vais lui envoyer mon
sens pourri dans les veines
là ça devient grave problème non non je
trouve que on a enfin moi j'ai en moi
la violence est là j'ai en moi des
désirs l'engagement politique aussi
contre je suis vers le fascisme je sais
pas pas le fascisme et fuir c'est la
littérature je te dis pas que je vais le
faire mais c'est vrai qu'on peut penser
des choses comme ça et l'idée de l'idée
d'aller avec une seringue compte un
fasciste
je vois pas ce que je trouve ça
fabien c'est normal tous pas ça normal
mais je pense qu'on peut y penser oui ça
c'est un monde assez crépusculaire quand
même c'est à dire il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'amour d'amitié encore moins mystique
moi c'est quand même très froides
crépusculaire non je suis pas daccord
partir du moment où le narrateur il
il se pose c'est quand même écrit noir
sur blanc je ne sais pas aimé puis
quelqu'un qui dit je sais pas aimé ça
prouve quand même qu'ils se posent la
question que l'amour c'est au centre de
sa vie
reconnaître ses incapacités ses doutes
c'est quand même aussi un privilège de
l'homme qui pense faire le type qui a
que des certitudes
c'est un facho il était admis comment
ils ont réagi aux livres
ce sont des gens à paris qui savait pas
que qui avaient des problèmes de
séropositivité paris c'était quand même
des gens qui n'ont appris un jour en
recevant hambourg ouais on regarde si on
disait je crois que ça je crois que ça
fait des catégories il ya des gens qui
s'en vont et des gens qui restent
et puis
en fait la crise a fait le tri et si
c'était à refaire alors tu en 79
ouais maths spé match exact de match si
c'était à faire du bien si tu
connaissais la fin de l'histoire je
prendrai le même chemin que c'est une
bonne question à laquelle j'ai jamais
réfléchi ce soit changera rien qu'on
dira mais tu peux appeler chien
qu'est-ce que tu freines 7-6 7/3 je suis
quelqu'un qui je suis quelqu'un quand
même d'assez livre j'ai à peu près
toujours fait ce que je voulais donc si
j'ai fait ça c'est peut-être que j'avais
à le faire
quant à l'avenir du bas comment ben
écoute
je vais tourner un film en décembre
j'ai des idées de bouquins
je vais peut-être faire un film avec ce
livre et puis peut-être que je vais
apprendre à aimer un peu plus si les
cloîtres sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu